[Musique]
je sais comment jouer à ce jeu là comme
dans la vie il faut prévoir les qu il ne
s'agit pas de savoir où on en est je ne
peux pas répondre à vos questions en
même temps mais de savoir où on en sera
dans dix coups ou dix ans
une crise cardiaque
comment ça peut lui arriver va pas être
en meilleure forme que nous faisons il
ya en fait une chose dont nous devons
discuter
qu'est ce que c'est ton père a laissé ce
un portois rien
et toi seul est ce qu'une seule fille
sur terre connaît vraiment son père
montre moi ton visage
lauren elisabeth mon nom
t'es pas comme lui mon avis tu meilleur
qu'il ne l'a jamais été
qui êtes-vous j'aime bien penser que je
suis un membre de la famille après
toutes ces années
est ce que papa avait des ennemis dont
je devrais être informé tu sais bien que
c'était pas un saint si une personne
menacée notre famille je jetterai son
corps dans la rivière
nick tu avais pas peur de la vérité
il ya des secrets que j'emporterais dans
ma tombe si tu m'apportes que je te
demandais je te promets de tout raconter
est ce que vous vous moquez de moi
est ce que mon père me cacher à autre
chose
l'avocate un dentier un politicien a qui
te parle est la pire des trinités ton
père n'avait pas le droit de faire ce
qu'il a fait sacrée famille
tout ça nous prouve rien de toi
triathlon
mais une fois que je t'aurais tout dit
tu connaîtras la vérité
et là je sais que tu me libère
la vérité doit rester au tél
[Musique]